heute gibt es bei uns ein einfaches
ofengericht zur Mittagspause dafür
schneide ich einfach Kartoffeln in
mundgerechte Stücke und verrühre
Gemüsebrühe mit Gewürzen das kommt dann
direkt über die Kartoffel so dass sie im
Ofen schon mal vorgaren können in der
Zwischenzeit kann ich das restliche
Gemüse in kleine Stücke schneiden nehmt
da einfach was ihr gerne essen ich habe
mich jetzt hier für grünes Gemüse
entschieden
[Musik]
rührt jetzt auch eine cremige Soße aus
Milch Schmand und Käse und natürlich
Gewürzen an
[Musik]
und sobald die Kartoffeln dann vorgegart
sind nehmt ihr das Gemüse das kommt über
die Kartoffeln Soße drüber und ab in den
Backofen so kann alles fertig garen
richtig lecker schnell gemacht und ich
serviere es einfach mit etwas Chiliöl
[Musik]